- [Raimundo] Puerto Rico's my home.
I've really devoted a
lot of my life and career
to protecting Puerto
Rico's natural resources.
So when Hurricane Irma
and Maria hit Puerto Rico,
there was devastation
throughout the entire island.
And so this is something that I felt that
we really had to address and take action.
Commercial fishermen in Puerto Rico
are providing the base to
a lot of economic growth.
While every industry was really affected,
fishing communities
were severely impacted.
A lot of fishing gear that was near shore
was pulled back into the
ocean by the hurricane.
This is something that was
of great personal concern
just because this causes
them to be ghost traps.
Ghost traps are a real problem
for the marine environment
because they continued fishing.
So they're catching fish and
other species that die off,
serve no purpose for
the marine environment,
and have no benefit to
commercial fishermen.
We really wanted to see
how we could address
helping out fishing communities
while at the same time
cleaning up this derelict fishing gear.
We really wanted to collaborate
with dive fishermen in Puerto Rico.
Because of this incredible knowledge
that they have that nobody
else has of the sea floor.
And because we wanted to
provide an alternative income
during the aftermath of Hurricane Maria
to really help them move forward.
When the fishermen go out fishing,
they're underwater collecting fish.
And while they're down there,
they identify where
ghost traps are located,
and then they'll give me a call.
(splashing)
So I'll come out the next day or two
and start pulling up this gear.
The fishermen are
compensated for their time,
and they're really brought as
collaborators on the project.
We covered all of Puerto Rico.
It's just over 15 communities
that have participated in this effort.
We've been able to remove
just under 400 ghost traps,
and it totals up to 7 tons
of derelict fishing gear
that we've removed from
Puerto Rico's ocean.
After the impact of Hurricane Maria,
we really felt alone.
But it really brought a lot
of Puerto Rico together.
Without the local knowledge
of these fishermen,
we would not have been
able to come together
as a people to really
survive and move forward
to see how things can improve here,
and it's something that we
need to continue recognizing.
Not just for fishing communities,
but for all response to emergencies.
(chiming)